and new tonight a brand new resource
from the clark county district
attorney's office hopes to help domestic
violence survivors navigate the criminal
justice system now the ultimate goal is
to put those abusers behind bars
erkomana explains what it is and how
survivors are responding
mentally physically
just emotionally abusive situation
courtney dillon is a domestic violence
survivor she's no longer with the
partner who hurt her but she'll never
forget what happened hitting him in the
face kicking me in the stomach still she
never took him to court i was just
scared about the retaliation
like if i were to go through the court
system and it didn't work out even for
survivors with cases in court there's a
lot of fear that's why the clark county
district attorney's office created this
new website dvhelp lasvegas.com it
answers questions about subpoenas
feeling too scared to testify against
abusers and what actually happens in
court survivors can also look up their
cases and get access to other resources
this website provides them with
information they can use to make them
feel more comfortable about
participating in the court process clark
county district attorney steve wolfson
tells me hearing their stories makes all
the difference we lose a significant
percentage of cases because we don't
have our victims the larger goal is to
save lives the latest numbers from metro
police show there have been 17 domestic
violence homicides in 2021 through
september 24th in comparison there were
13 through that same point last year
that's a 31 percent increase the hope is
to put abusers behind bars before things
escalate we're here to help that's a
promise courtney is happy to hear having
someone like the d.a like be like hey
i'm listening and like i'm here
would be
i think it's
really good orco mana live local now